I was talking to a friend of mine and she was telling me that her dad had been
hospitalized and while her dad was hospitalized a,
he was in like this,
uh,
like,
like a care home for older people.
And I'm a guy who has schizophrenia,
will freaked out and tried to eat him.
Oh God.
While he was there.
Yeah.
And then he said,
fuck this,
get me out of here.
And he wound up dying at home.
We want to dying at home rather than die in the hospital because a guy tried to
eat him.
Imagine like your last days of life are escaping a schizophrenia guy who got out
of his room and tried to eat it.
This is why I work so hard all my life and raised a family and now I'm here.
I mean that started your worst fears to be,
to die away from your loved ones.
Just around strangers to be back at the first day of high school basically.
But you're old and everyone's old,
but then someone's trying to kill you and eat you.
We don't,
we don't get rid of people like that quick enough.
Like,
you know,
you get rid of bad dogs,
dogs bite people.
You like to put them down,
put them dot.
Yeah.
It's what I should,
I got to tell my mother that because she works with this group called the
village,
which creates a network in any given neighborhood where if you're young or
you're old,
you're registered and cost thing and basically,
uh,
this person can live out their,
their final years in their home because they have a network of neighbors who
check on them like every couple hours or call me,
here's my cell.
That's like I have,
I'm having a chest pain.
Okay,
cool.
Let's just get you to the hospital.
Cause it's like at the Va,
I think people deserve to,
you know,
as long as you're not eating people and killing them,
they can die in their homes.
You know?
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a concern that you really don't ever want to address it until it's too
late.
Yeah.
The dude,
the concern of when and how do I go?
Yeah.
You know,
I mean you have to accept that you're going to go and some people just have a
really hard time with that.
Sure.
Even deep into their old age when they're decrepit and they can't make it any
more,
they just can't handle the fact that it's all going to end.
No,
no,
I mean it.
That's why you have to live your life to the fullest and not a bite your tongue
and just be yourself because yes,
or just chill the fuck out and wait for the end.
What do you do?
One of the two,
I don't know.
What is the life to the fullest,
right.
If it's all temporary share anyway,
they absolutely,
I mean there,
there is that point where it's just like,
well,
is there any point to life?
I don't know.
I've gone back and forth the Trussell on this where I'm just like,
Dunkin.
Yeah,
Duncanville.
Fucking send you down a rabbit hole with that man.
I don't know man.
Yeah,
the cosmic
and he'll make some sense out of it too.
He will.
He is the cosmic trickster without a doubt.
I were Bordain speaking Bourdain.
He was the,
he was staying there like,
how would you like to go?
And he was just like,
I just want just one bullet in the back of my skull and I don't see a comment.
Yeah.
But meanwhile he did it himself and dealing with a rope.
It's just,
I was friends with them.
I didn't fuck me up.
Fuck me up.
I wasn't,
and I was a fan of his since the first article came out in the New Yorker that
he wrote,
it fucks you up because you just go,
I wish he called me.
Yeah,
I wish.
I mean I would've flown to France.
No,
I wouldn't have,
I it suck it up.
Pussy.
Don't kill yourself in France,
in back to America.
She would have checked in because I mean,
I think it's all about perspective.
There are times where we've all come close to not necessarily putting a gun in.
Our mouths were rope around her neck.
But where'd you just feel like there's no point you no,
but someone can just come in.
I say it like coming up in the,
in the crew that I came up with in Chicago,
you know,
Canadian and Hannibal.
Uh,
and,
and people like,
we,
we never let each other get away with shit or it's just like,
yeah,
you're saying that,
but fuck you.
Like you need those people in your life.
I'll never forget.
I went through a horrible breakup and I went,
I was in my apartment for like a week,
only leaving to wait tables and bartending.
And then I finally came to a show and Canadians like,
hey,
look who pushed aside all the clumps used Kleenex,
be with us.
Welcome back you fucking pussy.
And I remember laughing so hard and it all went away.
It all went away.
You just cause you take yourself so seriously and yours are going to get better.
And it's,
I mean,
I just think about despair as this demon that latches onto your back and it's
your job to fuck it up,
get it off you.
You know,
what's your thing,
uh,
destroy,
fight the bitch in you talk earlier.
Yeah.
You're in a bitches.
I usually,
when I'm referring to your inner pitch,
I mean the inner bitch who doesn't want you to work out.
Yes.
Well that's,
that's,
that's the one I relate to the most where it's,
I feel that every time I'm in a class,
every time I'm in something like that,
it's just like something and you're just like,
I just want to sandbag it.
Let me just Sam.
But just this time,
well,
I mean,
everybody has that.
Yeah,
I still have it,
but I've got that motherfucker on lockdown.
Good.
Now I own him.
He's in there though.
He's weak.
You never see.
Oh,
he's always trying to tell you you don't,
you can take the day off.
Maybe your ankle sore.
Maybe.
Maybe you're feeling a little sick,
a little run down,
you know,
just take a,
take a you day.
The dog looks tired.
He doesn't even want to run.
You know,
it's not about you.
You should take care of that dog.
Dog does not want to run.
My Dad said something brilliant on the floor.
My Dad lately,
like he's always been like a guy.
No words.
You mentioned,
uh,
like hospice living and stuff.
My Dad used to do hospice and he,
he would just,
he was like,
do I have to talk?
And the guy's like,
no,
you can.
I just mostly want to someone to listen.
He's like,
I can do that and do it.
Sit by dying people and just nod his head and stuff.
And uh,
but he never,
he never talk about it where I'd be like,
Dad,
what are you doing today is like,
Oh,
I'm gonna go hang out with bill.
Like Dad,
why the fuck is bill is this guy,
he's dying.
Like,
Dad,
you got to tell me more than this.
So now we're kind of,
he's opening up more,
but long story long,
he was like,
you know,
when you're waking up in the middle of the night and there's that voice in your
head that is telling you you're,
you're,
you're useless and you're,
you haven't done enough with your life and things like that.
He's like,
I don't know if there is a devil,
but if there is,
that's him.
And I was like,
fuck.
And it just blew my mind.
Right.
And it's like,
dad,
you're right.
That voice that tells you to give up that voice that tells you not to,
not,
not to,
you know,
to hate yourself and to,
don't think you're worthy.
Well,
it's such a weird pattern,
right?
Because it doesn't have any real evolutionary benefit,
but yeah.
What is the benefit of self loathing and,
and just sitting around feeling pity.
Yeah.
There,
there are plenty of people in situations that are going to kick the shit out of
you in life anyway.
Why?
Why do it to yourself?
But yeah.
But there's something good about feeling very disappointed in yourself because
then it makes you work harder and like you recognize or at least try to realize
your potential better and you get more done.
You feel better about yourself.